hurt a lot because it was the thing I
loved the most but they were using that
word and insulting me with it okay so I
got called a Trekkie which I guess when
I was younger I didn't realize I wasn't
cool and like the stuff that I was into
wasn't cool so venom is this a
spider-man character that is made of
black goo and he has like big white eyes
and really jagged teeth um it's probably
surprising or hard to imagine but when I
was a little kid my skin with you and
fairer than it is now my existence from
the age of eleven until the age of
seventeen when I left high school was
miserable my hair was very short and I
didn't have a very straight teeth so I
think when people saw me I just kind of
resembled a character to them and it was
really hurtful because I cared so much
about Star Trek and thought it was so
neat and instead it turned into an
insult and yeah it hurt a lot
probably the most common name that they
called me was ghost anytime there was a
scary story or something they'd be like
and it was Hannah at the end not only
did I get called ugly but I had a bottle
thrown at my head one time I got slammed
into a door started this whole insecure
downward spiral of me as a teen going to
tanning beds all the time and trying to
be something I wasn't you know I did I
did really well for myself like I go out
of that town I got masters from Columbia
on a competitive scholarship so thanks
for I guess that shitty experience made
me into a very strong person
when it exploded it felt really good to
just see it explode just boom up like
that feels like it takes the word away
from them and now it can be my word kind
of a thing that lingers and weighs on
you and so that I was not expecting to
feel so happy after doing that but I'm
like overjoyed right yeah you know we're
all in this together we should be nice
we should be kind to each other and just
make it like as pleasant as possible
while we're here
Oh